Hey,
if you're listening to this podcast and
you enjoy it and you really like it and
you're thinking to yourself,
I want to support Conan,
I want to help him in his quest to make
the greatest podcast that ever was or
ever will be. Well, if you
want to help, uh, you can,
you see we need the help of some great
advertisers and in order to find great
advertisers, we actually need to
know a little bit more about you.
Not in a creepy way and a helpful way.
So if you're interested in helping out,
please go to pod survey.com/conan
that's pod survey.com/conan.
Take a quick anonymous survey that will
help us get to know you a little better.
That way we can show advertisers
have right our listeners are,
and then the whole thing comes
together in a beautiful way. Plus,
once you've completed the survey,
you can choose to enter for a chance to
win a $100 Amazon gift card. Of course,
terms and conditions apply.
So again,
that's pod survey.com/conan and uh,
thanks very much for even thinking
about lending a hand. Appreciate it.
Hi,
my name is will Ferrell
and I feel awkward about
being Conan O'brien's friend.
Hey,
welcome to Conan O'brien needs a friend.
This is the podcast where I Conan talk
to people I've interviewed over the years
on my TV job and try and figure
out what's really the deal with us.
Are we friends? He said all
fake. What's going on with us?
That's my quest and I'm joined by,
I would say trusty assistant.
I don't think that's, I don't think your
trusty assistant, but Sonoma obsession.
What do you think, trustee? Hello. Okay.
And of course Matt Gorley, who's a
podcast extraordinary and an expert.
Oh, hi. You are. You're very
good at this podcast stuff.
And so are you and I thank you.
I don't know anything about it.
I am just babbling,
which I've done since I was born,
but you have been mad skills to make
sense of all of this and I appreciate you
being here. The three of us together.
We're going to get our way through this.
You were really nice to him and you
were the main amazing, so shitty to me.
It wasn't Shitty to you said,
are you trustee you for
a very long time and uh,
and what,
and I think I've done a good percentage
of the things that you've asked me to do
over the areas above 60% I
don't think over, I think, no,
I don't think, you know,
you're like chose dude.
You're like, oh my God, you're wonderful.
And it's not just impressed that
he's so skilled at what he does,
but you are a nice person. Wait a
minute. What am I not a nice person?
I don't know. I don't know you
personally. Yeah. Maybe we'll be friends.
They last night.
You're across from me wearing a
headset and that's not going to happen.
You spend so much time doing podcasts.
I'm sure that you're just in sufferable.
That's sadly true, right? Yeah.
You're constantly saying, boy,
this is a great chicken sandwich, but now
a word about this amazing new mattress.
This is hitting home. See that's where
I could teach you a thing or two.
I appreciate it.
Yeah.
Today's guest is will Farrel.
I don't think anybody's ever made me
laugh harder than will Pharrel and he's a
right here and he's got the dead eyes
of a shark will Pharrel. Hey will.
What I love about the audio
space so that the right term yes,
is that it's refreshing
and there's a certain,
there's a level of honesty or at least
perceived honesty when you're listening
to these things. So you know, that's what
a like a Mark Marin or people like me,
I think that's his is so good.
What'd you do that for?
Which do that for what number
podcasts is this for you, by the way?
I think the 200 and
this is maybe the first,
this might be the first trial balloon.
This is the first time I've heard my
own speaking voice and you're loving it.
Horrible. I, I sound
like a an irate woman.
You have a good voice. Don't sell
yourself. I don't love my voice.
I want to say I want to start it with
this. I don't think he should be here.
I think it was a mistake.
You are two biggest star to come in.
You have lowered yourself to be here.
This was a mistake.
I am just focusing on the sound
blankets taped to the walls here.
This is the room where they shot Joe Pesci
in Goodfellas where they've stenciled
Conan.
Yeah.
It really does look like we're preparing
for a murder. This is, this is crazy.
Why would you, what kind of, what's
what with your management when,
when cy told you, I told you when I saw
you. Yeah. Um, you grabbed me by the show.
I said,
I will not do your podcast.
You said that and you said it was the
conviction of a man whose legs were on
fire and I thought he's telling the truth.
You went, okay. Okay. All right. Yeah.
Yeah. And I respected you for that
decision. Your Will Ferrell you've made.
And then I came over for movies over
over four movies in Jamaica alone.
Yes. Yeah. We'll get back to that.
I know you're a management and
Mister Jimmy Miller, right.
I think he made a mistake. I think,
I don't think you should be here.
I think this was, well, I'm here. This
was an easy pass for you and a you.
She can pass right now. You can and we
can just cut this thing in half. Yeah,
or not even an a half.
Yeah, but you're here. God,
I want to walk out the store right
now that you can't the doors,
you don't seal it. Oh my God. It has
elderly. They're sealing it right now.
They have welding and the extra for
any blankets. So just a couple. Uh,
not very recently.
You never know when these things are,
so I'm just going to say very recently
I shared the stage with you at the Greek
theater and you were Ron Burgundy and
you were, when you become Ron Burgundy,
you do things that no one
else in comedy can do.
I was stood backstage and you as Ron
started to talk about for any other
comedian, it would be an aside, you
just mentioned, we're here at the Greek.
It's nice. We're nestled in the hills
here in Hollywood right now. Some wolves.
You started to talk about wolves being
in the hills and I watched as you talked
about wolves coming out of
the hill, coyotes, coyotes,
coyotes for maybe 15 minutes
and you wouldn't let it go.
And it was hilarious.
You went at least 14 minutes longer than
any other human would ever go on about
coyotes. Yeah, there is. Um,
there's something about doing Ron Burgundy
because he's an expert on everything
in his own mind. And it's great
if the audience is laughing.
They were laughing very hard.
Yeah.
But it's even better when they're not
because I just love to punish them and
just they can't go anywhere. And Ron
just has a captive audience. What's Nice,
because it's not you in that
moment. You will, is somewhere else.
Ron is on stage. There's also just
screaming names of communities at them.
Yes. Because if you've been to the Greek
theater for those listeners at home,
it's up in the Los Feliz area, Griffith
Park area. And so I kept talking.
I kept referencing though communities
down in San Diego. Yeah. Cause I'd driven,
I'd rented a car to drive
to the Greek theater,
but I kept saying I had a
list of like 15 communities,
which are foreign to the La audience,
but I just like any one
from Rancho Penasquitos here
and would just be like a
smattering of applause. I want,
I hear you and can Tada
and,
but somehow they came, they came
with me on it and I just kept, yeah.
Well then you started talking
about how when you're driving up,
you're on the one oh one but then you
get on the one 34 so you switched to the
five and seven 10 and this the seven 10
and again, I kept saying, stay with me,
stay with them.
But what I loved as a
longtime admirer of yours,
I get to ask this a lot. People say,
who makes you laugh the hardest?
And I consistently say,
will Pharrel because he doesn't care.
He goes down these deep,
deep wells.
He does not care if you're
coming with him or not.
And you follow him out of fascination.
And I don't know where that comes from.
You have, you have dead shark eyes
and you, I think it's that thing,
you know, and it happened on my, um,
audition for Sarah and I live,
you know,
they do it different every year as
you know. But that year that I did it,
everyone had to do it
in eight h and it was,
there's no audience and they're just a
camera and someone holding a boom Mike.
Yeah. And just the glow of Lorne Michaels
cigarette as he smokes it. No. Uh,
but it doesn't smell the darker
where you're literally alone.
Yes. And it's so intimidating
and so awful that I was like,
oh,
it can't get any worse than this,
so I'll just cry to relish the moment.
So that same,
I've,
I've kind of just followed that practice.
You've always done that.
I remember early on when you were
in Charlotte live and you were not,
you did well right away, but you
were sort of sort of, but it hadn't,
I was announced the most annoying
newcomer where you realize, yeah. Okay.
Cherio Terry was like the outbreak star
and then will Ferrell most unknowing
newcomer. Yeah. Okay. There's one guy not
to watch, this guy won't shut up. Yeah.
But she would have forgotten about
that. Oh, I say my prayers every night.
So Erin member that I was doing the late
night show on the sixth floor because
when did you start? You just
start 93 or 95. Okay. Yup.
So right around the time my show is
sort of starting to gel and get up and
running. It took us about two
years to figure out which,
what the hell we were doing.
Right. But, uh, I remembered, uh,
a guy who worked on our show also hung
out at Saturday night live and he was
talking about you. Okay. And he said,
there's this guy will Pharrel
and he's really funny,
but he does these things and I don't
know if he's kidding or not or if he's
crazy. And I said, what do you mean? And
he said he did is tell me if this is true.
This is what I heard at the time. Right.
And I'm pretty sure it's not lore.
He told me that now this guy will,
this kid will,
the last sketch that he was
in on Saturday night live,
he had to be dressed in a certain costume.
Oh, the Jerry Reed outfits and like a,
like a full on country Music Star outfit
and he wore it to the after party,
which turning left always has and
then continued to wear it for weeks.
Well knowing for weeks, for
the whole entire second half
of the season. Yes, yes,
yes. And I had a friend of mine
then people started to tell me,
I kept thinking he's going to drop it.
So then weeks later someone would say,
I was at the Natural History Museum
and I saw will Pharrel walking down the
street in his country. Western
college. Describe the outfit too.
Yeah. Wrangler jeans, like 19
seventy's Nike track shoes,
a Western shirt with a down vest
and a trucker's cap chapters cat.
And I was playing Jerry Reed.
Yup. Uh, from the smoking ban.
Great Museum in a,
in a sketch that for some
reason you remember how the
shooting days when it SNL,
we had a pre tape but I should be shot
part of it in the first part of the day
and we weren't shooting the
second part till the next.
So I decided I'm going to hang out with
my Jerry Reed costume all day during
rehearsal and whatever. But then I
decided to wear it to the after party.
Then I wear it to the pitch
meeting the following Monday.
And then it was this writer
Tom Janice who was like,
yeah cause it was a run of three shows.
He's like,
please wear it for the next show too.
So I started wearing it show week
number two, then show week number three.
And I thought, okay, this was funny
enough. And it was, Tom was like,
please wear it for the rest of the year.
It'll be so inspirational.
And I'm like, you're right
Tom. I have to do this.
I don't know why this is what separate.
I don't know why this was the
edge of honor. Yeah. So I'm like,
there's no reason not to.
And it became this beautiful comedy
litmus test and it would get funnier and
funnier and funnier to people.
Other people would be like,
there are other people who are more of
the staff would be like, what'd you stop?
What's wrong with you right now?
I didn't wear it consecutive.
I would launder it on occasion,
but for the most part I wore it
from February to May. Yes. Yeah.
And at one point I had Alec Baldwin
was hosting and he said, uh, I,
those are normal clothes.
Is this an outfit you normally wear?
And I go, I go, I don't know
how to explain this to you,
but no, this is like a long
running joke. He's like, good,
because it's not a good look for you.
And I could see him with
those eyes piercing and he
was giving me like brotherly
advice and I go, oh no, I,
I, I know it's not, but I'm,
but once again, that
became a thing where, oh,
I got to keep wearing it. And a, yeah,
finished out the year
wearing the preread office.
You also did something that no one's
ever done before, which I loved.
Again, I'm doing my show. I
love, I'm trying to, I'm doing
my show. What it will be.
I'll tell you, I think
you'll remember. Okay.
I'm doing my show down on late night
and at the late night show, and again,
we're just a couple of floors. You guys
were on the sixth floor, sixth floor.
And so you,
you,
you came to us and you said,
I have a funny idea and I don't
think they like it sound out live,
but I could do it on your show.
And we said, sure. And you know,
we're doing an hour a night.
And so you played a
character called scrub a dub.
Oh No, this was, this was written.
It was Adam McKay was written by
Adam McKay, the great Adam McKay.
But you, you played scrub a
dub and Adam McKay wrote it.
And so you guys came to us.
It was both of you and said,
can we do it on your show? And we were
like, Eh, you know, it was someone saying,
do you want a Bugatti? Yes,
yes, we want to Bugatti.
You guys came and scrub a dub a, it's
hard to describe, but he's psycho.
Mr Clean of noxious. Mr Clean. He's an
obnoxious Mr. Clean who's out of control.
And it was a sketch where we're going to
have a website soon where you can look
up all the old stuff in,
in high resolution and this is what it's
going to like a running ad throughout
your show.
It was a running ad.
You Clive ad you kept
interrupting and I would move on.
You'd say I'm scrubbing up and you were,
I think you were bald and
you had a muscular and
muscular Mr clean outfit. Yup.
And then I would say, okay, well that's
great. Scrub a dub. And I would move on.
And then you'd be in the corner
and you'd be playing craps. Yeah,
the die with dice and you'd be on, come
on, come on and look, be my lead it.
And I scrub a dog.
And you kept it got violent.
It got out of control at one
point of spray painting on your,
you were on the set is kept interrupting.
So here's the crazy thing about it.
No one had told Lauren.
No one had asked Laurence
permission because we didn't know.
We didn't know anything. We're all kids,
we're all kids and we're all just doing,
well this is funny. They wouldn't do it
on turn it left. So we'll do it here.
Just bring it down to the next thing.
We get this call from Lauren who's
executive producing our show,
but he doesn't know. They sure if we just
get this call, which is like, you know,
if you're going to use my people,
would you let me?
And I think you got to talking to you.
I did too. You got to talking to you.
And I think, uh, Adam [inaudible]
got a talking to which was,
you know, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. But we were
just completely like, well, oh,
they don't want to use it
here. Let's just, well, let's
call it Conan and his guys.
And that started this thing where the
most consistent thing I hear from fans is
that your appearances were always
these conceptual thought pieces,
comedy pieces,
the where you would commit.
And your commitment would make me commit.
I would never say this is a bit, right.
So,
so there's the time you through
a very complicated pre tapes,
you heckled yourself playing a guy with
a mustache and a Michael Jackson glove
and a Michael Jackson
jacket that was too small.
So you came out to try stand up will
Pharrel and then we cut to you with a
mustache. Yeah, heckling yourself.
And then the heckling gets between
the two of you and you say, Hey,
I'm just trying to do something here.
And then you as yourself being a total
dick and you kept kept wiping the
mustache with your finger and gesturing
to it and being a total prick.
And then you charged yourself and
everyone in the audience was like,
well how's this going to happen? Cause
the guy in the audience has a pre tay.
Oh that's right.
How are you two going to interface?
And then we cut to you insisted on a
body double. And who was a little person,
you know Michael Jack and a
Michael Jackson Jacket, right?
Who tackles you since suddenly
the reads me up you up.
It doesn't match you in any way,
shape or form.
Thank God for your late night
show because that was like,
that was like comedy heaven where I knew
there were other talk shows that were,
you know, very lovely to do. Yup. However,
they had their set rules as to what
they were comfortable doing and you guys
were always like, let's do it.
Let's try it right there was,
there was one where you,
we have the drum off. Yes.
I wanted to show off my drumming against
a nine year old kid and it was a nine
or 10. He was like 11, 11. Yeah.
What a really good drummer and I can't
play and he blows me away and I chased
him off the set. Um,
yeah, I mean that was a,
I was once doing Charlie rose and he
was asking about doing late night TV and
all the talk shows.
And I literally started going
down like just unabashedly going,
oh, this one's fun. You know, you
know, always doing Letterman. It's,
it's such an odd thing, but, but
hands down, Conan is the bass.
And Charlie was when careful,
like you didn't want me to play
favorites in any way, but I'm like,
I mean he's the,
and I saw what he was,
he was trying to not let me put
my foot in my mouth. But no,
you guys were proven that his judgement
was fast. Yes. You only have to wait.
We have to take a quick break.
We'll be right back.
And now it's time for a segment
called Conan O'Brien pays off
the mortgage on his beach house.
Yeah, we've been over this before,
but I took a pretty large mortgage and
then I borrowed against the mortgage and
then I took another mortgage.
Financially, not the smartest move.
That sounds like a lot of bad decisions,
but if it's enabled me to, uh, read ads,
then maybe it's led me to
my true calling in life.
Don't you think you can add
reading is your true calling?
It might be the only thing
I do. Well, I decided
this may surprise some people,
but I am not just a podcaster.
I also dabble in a little something
called television. Oh yeah.
For a little while. Just 25 years. Okay.
Sorry to come across angry. Anyway,
I have this TV show that I've been
taking all over the world. Uh,
and I love doing this. I've gone
to places like Cuba, Armenia.
We went to Armenia. SONA. That
was fun. Yeah, we went to Haiti.
We went to South Korea.
So many different countries.
I love these episodes.
Well,
I just want to tell you
that my new episode of Conan
Without Borders is about to
come out and in this one
I traveled to Japan. Sona,
you've seen the Japan show.
It's absolutely hilarious.
Yeah, it's really funny.
It's really funny.
There's a lot of fun surprises in it.
Very proud of this episode. You
visit a place called Conan town. Yes.
In Japan. I have a lot of
adventures. There's a few.
There's a little guest appearance there.
It's really fun.
And so I'm hoping people will
check it out. Kona Without Borders.
Japan air is November 28th on TBS and
make sure to visit [inaudible] dot com
slash Japan to look at all kinds
of behind the scenes stuff, extras,
live streams and more.
And then we're back. Just like that. Yeah.
We did nothing. That was a good break.
Your level of commitment was
what we were talking about.
And I tell people that weight back,
sorry. Yeah. Back to Ron Burgundy. Yes.
At this live charity show.
Yeah.
I didn't even tell you about this
component because Jerry Seinfeld was doing
standup as part of our show and I
ran into his longtime manager, uh,
George Shapiro. [inaudible] Shapiro. Yeah.
And he has very set rules as to hell.
Jerry likes to be introduced
and doesn't want a lot of, uh,
they just want ladies and gentleman, Jerry
Seinfeld, and he has to have a stool.
And you know, every comedian has
their particular things that they,
they want a certain way. And so
he was like, uh, he was like,
Ron Burgundy, I love it. It's going
to enter and you know, keep it short.
And I was like, well, you got
to tell that to Ron Burgundy.
And then I could tell it made his head
spin in such a way because I knew we had
this crazy intro for Jerry
as Ron that, yeah. Yeah. Um,
and luckily Jerry thought
it was really fun.
I was backstage because we
had just finished our bit.
I'm standing backstage and when Jerry
is about to go on behind and so I was
standing here cause I'm just,
you know,
interested to see the transition and uh,
you know the crowd excited about Conan
and then just sort of having to settle
down for Jerry.
Yeah.
Well Jerry was brought in to cool
it off a little bit after Kona,
which is generally his role. Well we shut
the show down. Yeah. The cool it down.
Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, so Jerry comes in
and you know, crowds filing out. Um,
he's not, I'm told he's not
that powerful in my business.
I'm just going to go after him. He's
not, he can't hurt you. Yeah, he can't.
No one can, you can hear a lot of
people. We can't hurt you. No, no, no.
I'm in a very snowman about the main
man effected by as Ferny blankets.
So, uh, but yeah, you go on and on and
on and you start listing his credits,
which includes,
you've seen him on the Arsenio Hall show.
This is for Jerry Seinfeld. Um, uh,
know him from Arsenio Hall. Yeah.
Magic Johnson talked to him.
You know him from the
Seinfeld show reruns.
You listen to the local affiliate. Anyway,
he was backstage and he was howling,
which was, he was really loud.
He wrote me a really nice,
he said he had a great time and um,
and I'm like,
thanks for indulging wrong with the
long. He's like, oh yeah, I loved it.
But anyway, you and I have
something in common. We both same.
We share the same birthday. No, we don't
know. And then we can go, sorry, go ahead.
I got excited for [inaudible] like I've
never seen you at Denny's for the free
cake on the day. I'm there. You're always
there. Denny's, right? You were, yeah,
I can get a free cake. Forget it.
I uh, I was in the Groundlings.
I was in the Groundlings before.
You were a contemporary of Lisa Kudrow,
Lisa Kudrow and then I,
shall I say she was a view
that means no.
So you start by taking the class.
That's what happens at the Groundlings
here in Los Angeles. You take the classes,
they have really names beginning,
intermediate and advanced.
So what I've always thought was hilarious
was Lisa was so hysterically funny and
some people have sometimes thought,
they sometimes make people repeat at the
Groundlings just to get, but you know,
we'll make a little more money,
you know. So uh, there was,
Lisa was just hilarious than they were.
I remember them telling Lisa she
had to repeat it. You should, uh,
you should take this class again.
She'd get again.
I just think one more and
basically it was like, you know,
one more round of payments,
maybe really comedy chops.
That's hilarious.
She and I were there a at the same time
I didn't actually ever join the ground
is cause I left to right at sona out live.
But I did all the classes.
You went all the way.
Did you go to the Sunday?
She was about to go to the Sunday
show when I had to leave. Yeah,
for gainful employment, for gainful
employment rather than pay to be on stage.
So funny to talk to anyone who'd
come from second city in Chicago.
They were like, how would you make
it the grilling? So I'm like, no,
you had to pay to perform there. Yeah.
And then when you were on the main stage,
you finally didn't have to pay. I
didn't make any money. No, they, uh,
I think the key is that, uh, second city,
I think they serve drinks and they serve
food and you can buy t shirts in the
lobby. You can actually, the
Groundlings never cracked that. Oh. Uh,
but I did that and I remembered
hearing about you later on.
I remembered hearing about you at the
Groundlings as this incredibly funny guy.
My sister Jane was at the ground
and she said, there's this,
she would rave about you. And a
I said, from the thanks to Jane.
Yeah. I said, from the sound
of it, he doesn't have it
is what I said at the time.
I was very, uh, defensive. Yeah. He's
competitive without even knowing me.
All I heard was someone else's funny
and I said, doesn't sound funny to me.
And she hadn't even given an
example of how you might be funny.
That's all I needed to know. I shut it
down. I think that says a lot about you.
I don't see that. All
right. I just am very,
I root against other people in comedy.
What does that say about me?
I know so that they're awful human being.
Oh yes.
Oh yeah. When others succeed
in comedy, I'm enraged. Right?
Is that not good?
You need to let that go.
I want you to do worse than you're doing,
so I can feel better. I'm writing
me right. What's wrong with that?
You're not going to get anywhere on this
podcast, that's for sure. By the way,
my crusade after doing this is
to tell no one else to do it.
If you're going to tell that you're
going to spread that out, oh my God,
I'm getting right on the old social media.
Is that what it's called?
It's called the soul. It's helped
with the kid. I should know.
I was on Twitter for four days then.
Shut it down. Did you enjoy it?
I really, I got way too sweaty and
nervous is too much pressure. Yeah.
I don't read anything. Uh, no, no, no,
no. I'm not interested in anyone's.
Uh,
opinion of what I'm doing about my work,
not because I skinned, because
I'm thin skin. Totally.
And I'm don't want to hear an anonymous
person say, uh, who has nothing to lose.
Say Well, all the good reviews
that I have been forwarded
boards my cough button.
Well you don't have that next year.
We'll get enough budget for a cough
button. Okay. Geez Louise. Oh,
you some, we're going to have to edit this
whole plot. This shows you as a human,
I always get, I don't reveal, read
any reviews or anything, right.
Except for the idle. Like you should
read the one though. It's really,
it's a great one.
And it inevitably always starts with,
I've never liked this guy. Yeah. However,
he was a pleasant surprise in his
role as the cat burglar. Sona,
what do I read? Nothing I
read. No, no, no, no, no.
I mean novels, but only
through about me. No.
Do I read any press? It can be the most
glowing review of something you've done.
You won't read it. And the reason,
even if it's glowing, yep. Is that,
what will I find? If it's good,
you'll always find the one,
you will find the one thing that
makes you go really? Yeah. Yeah.
You know though, saddled with, you
know, a a horrible lack of humor.
Oh, Brian's managed to overcome
it. Uh, you know, whatever.
And then it goes on the same time.
Bad reviews are fun is when
something has done really well.
You can tell critical
masses, you know, we just,
some of the most amazing reviews we ever
got were, were uh, on stepbrothers. Yeah.
So we were already
feeling like, oh, this is,
this is hitting all the right spots
and we've, we've made something good.
And the best one was Roger Ebert and
the review was like, whatever you do,
do not see this movie. Oh Wow. And
not tell your friends about it.
Do not buy it when it comes out on DVD.
And I think he literally wrote like,
this is like the sign of the end times
that this kind of creative ventures being
supported. It is juvenile acid.
Like everything he just like,
and you're just like, why do
people, why are they making this?
And it was just old man voice as you
read it. And a, and we were like, ah,
that's so nice because we felt so good
that was so off and it was so off.
But it was only out of security.
Could we, could we read them?
I am happy if I've doubled
down or committed to something.
You mentioned Tom, Janice, Tom Tennis
helped direct writer, director,
a show in Chicago that I did way back
in 1988 you probably weren't born yet.
And Kirk and smuggle smile,
his stage show in Chicago.
And I used to do a character.
I would have Bob go out and very pompously
Bob Odenkirk would go out and pump
asleep.
Tell the crowd that thing of Conan through
Improv is working on a character and
he's going to come out now and he's
going to do his character and it's a very
rich character and you're to ask him
questions and we're all going to build the
character some more together. And it was
this very, cause. This is how, you know,
this really this thing. And, um,
and this is, it's in Chicago,
which is the birth Improv, really
Mecca. And they're going to,
and so by your questions,
you'll see Conan on stage.
I had more depth to his character. Ladies
and gentlemen, please welcome Spooner.
And I came out and I had a spoon wedged
in my eye and I talk like a pirate and I
go are, I'm spooning, I am spoon.
I and people were trying
to help me and the crowds,
so they would die or questions for
me and we will build the character,
see spooned IIB. Any questions? And
so these people would say things like,
what's your favorite song? Like
a, a classic song. Yeah. Uh,
it has river in it. Like they want me to
go spoon river instead of moon, reverend.
I go, I didn't know what you're talking
about. This spoonie spoons song.
Oh, spoonie spoonie and then
it was a total fuck you.
And then someone else would say,
what's your favorite way to lie
in bed with your girlfriend?
And instead of saying spooning,
I'd say on a spoonie spoonie bed,
the crowd would become enraged.
And this critic wrote a thing and he said,
I went to the show and I liked the show,
but then Mr Brian took the stage
with his spoon I character.
I saw him miss opportunity
after opportunity.
I was so happy. Got We're going
to, I did a lifetime movie,
which unfortunately I need to give
lifetime permission to aerate more often
cause not that many people,
but I always had this idea to take
comedy people and do a lifetime movie
straight up.
So we did a lifetime movie called deadly
adoption and it was amazing and we
played it totally straight and we all
the actors had to sign nondisclosure that
they would and guys on the cats were like,
this is supposed to be funny. I'm like,
no, this is just a change in
direction. I just loved the script.
So it's the most melodramatic,
it's this amazing kind of Meta thing.
Anyway to reviews,
rolling stone totally got what we
were doing but the New York Times,
television critic,
whoever this word was like,
it just baffled his mind
and said while Kristen Wig,
because proven she has
is a dramatic actress.
Mr Feral. If it's supposed
to be funny, it's not funny,
and as an actor he's terrible.
This,
he could not figure out what was going on,
which was bless absolute bliss.
Yeah. Yeah. The only thing I've ever
seen that that sort of, it's an analogy,
if you've seen the movie the right stuff,
there's a moment where I'm not. Okay,
well this is awkward.
You could have just how to ask you to
let it just edit me out when I say I have
not, I haven't seen it. Go ahead. If you
keep saying that. Okay, you can't edit.
We don't. We don't have the budget.
The right stuff. What is it about, oh,
it's about astronauts got space. Yes,
but anyway, but I haven't seen it,
but there's a part where they
get up into the atmosphere.
That part of the atmosphere that's not
yet outer space but not in the light gets
blue and it gets really weird.
I've always thought in comedy,
if you keep pushing something
beyond when it's not funny,
you can get to this.
It's then it's not funny then it's
really not funny and people are getting a
little irritated. If you keep going,
there's this little magical blue, um,
how light transition into you can,
yeah.
And I believe you are the a,
it's holding your hand over the flame
for a little while and just seeing how
long before it gets really hot.
You also did,
I was there when you got your Mark
Twain Award and it was the funniest
acceptance speech I've
ever seen anybody give.
And then you did this brilliant thing
where you'll find finally you're hoping
the Twain Award you say what you did well,
which I was,
so I had this idea and I was so thankful
that they said yes without a hitch
because I was preparing for this battle
because it can get stodgy that event,
right. And uh, and they want to see what
your speech is going to be ahead of time.
And I was thinking,
oh,
it'd be so funny cause you're handed the
bust and it sits on a stool while you
give your speech. And so I thought, God,
it'd be great to go to set
it down and just break it.
I miss the stool and have it just explode
on the stage. And then just play
off of the, oh Geez, what could so,
but, and I was thinking there, there'd
be like, well, we can't do that.
The sanctity of that,
when I was building up my,
my whole argument that the mark
Twain himself would have wanted this.
And luckily they were like,
hilarious. That's great. So, uh, yeah,
so they allowed me to do it.
They,
and I've been just very delicately
stacked a crumbled mass, yes.
Onto the stool and then read my speech
as if I was standing in front of a
perfectly intact twain award.
What's the audience gasp
mixed with realizing yes,
but it was all a set up, but
it was a, it was really fun.
And I can assure you the Oscars,
the Emmy's,
the Grammy's,
whenever you went up,
the Times I've done an award show
or Ben and around an award show,
they act like their award is,
there's no way the goblet that Christ
drank from and the last supper,
that's how they act like it. And if
you have a funny idea that involves,
they're like, well, we'd love
to help you. But that's some,
here's the thing that's an Emmy.
Um, let me get back to you.
So coated, we talked. Oh my God, we love
it. Um, however, is there any way? Yeah,
my favorite voice always goes up.
My favorite thing ever was I, uh,
not my favorite thing ever,
but involving in an award show.
One of my favorite moments was a, uh,
I did an NFL honors once and had,
I thought really good jokes,
jokes were fine.
And then I had really good slams on
the commissioner of football. Uh,
perfect. Roger Goodell,
Roger Goodell. Yeah. And, um,
were you hosting or hosting?
And so he comes in and he's this very,
uh,
really cool off, absolutely straight
cuts, all business, all business.
And he comes in and, but he, he
sees me a comedy guy. He says,
what hell you were asking Conan around.
Can't wait for tonight anyway, if for,
and I see what you're up to you
trickster. Right. And I said, uh,
we have a couple of jokes about you
when he said they're going to be fine,
they're going to be fine. Whatever you
want to do. And I said, you're sure?
And he said, sure, I'll take a look,
but where I'm fine with all of them.
I just want you to be you and have a good
time. And I said, well, thanks a lot,
Mr Goodell, please call me
Roger Goodell. It's like, okay.
And then not Roger, Roger, Roger Goodell,
the commissioner of foot. Yeah. Okay.
So then he turns and he walks over about
10 feet from me and he's talking to
someone and the woman, a person then
wouldn't gumbles woman come? No.
A woman comes over and hands him the
sheet of jokes and he reads through the
sheet of jokes and I have like six jokes
on him and then he hands the sheet back
to her and she comes over and he says,
uh, none of those are acceptable.
That's where like course eight seconds
had passed. Well, you have fun.
You minx that's what the,
uh,
that for one of those first SB years,
SNL was producing the sps.
Who did you norm Macdonald.
Norm was hosting is up radio city.
And I came out as Harry Carey
and they just wrote, you know,
we just went around the
room and rooster teeth.
Did you go after you want to have to
someone's teeth and you don't know who it
was, but you and you very prominent
quarterback at the time and you were like,
Gee, I think I'd have the
money to get his teeth fixed.
And they cut to him and this makes it,
please find it.
It makes it a thousand times
funnier. He is stoning you. Yes.
And there were other athletes and it
was just Harry Carey not really knowing
who's out there
thinking he was at the source awards or
something. I Dunno. And like just, anyway,
I was apparently it was talked about
in the halls of ESPN for decades later.
Like, well, let's not have another
will Ferrell Harry Carey moment. Yeah,
they're lost. I say, yeah, me too. Um,
I don't want to keep you any longer.
I know that you were having
facial surgery today.
I am having not only facial surgery,
but butt implants finally.
All right. And this is a big day and I'm
doing it myself. I'm not some mistake. No,
I can do it. If I've got a
monitor system, it'll be easy.
You're going to look at a table,
you're in the line of ticking them
on and acting it out and you can go,
I can go right now. Okay, that's
good on a podcast and act it out.
You're really good at picking
stuff out. Own Butt implants. Uh,
I maintained this was a
mistake. You shouldn't have
been here for this. We'll see.
Yeah, we'll see. You may find you
maintain a mistake and I will,
it will make it my crusade and my life's
work to tell people to not do this
podcast and you will,
I cannot thank you enough.
And um, I maintain your, there's
some funny people on the planet,
but a will Pharrel has them
all beat by a country mile.
I really believe that and I,
I've, you've done nothing.
I'm filled goodwill and warmth and good
sheer. Whenever I even think about you,
you've just spent such a good guy to me
over the years and I thank you from the
bottom of my heart and hilarious. Thanks
so much. Thanks everyone. Great job.
Everybody did. Nice. Great job. Yeah.
Hey,
all this fall,
I've been checking something off my
bucket list for years and years and years.
It's been my dream to go out on tour,
hit the road with some of my favorite
comics and I've been doing that.
In fact right now I'm recording
this in my hotel room in Austin,
Texas because we got a show here tonight.
Yeah. It's a nice hotel room. Yes sir.
Than Mine.
It's much nicer than yours.
I put you in the same room as the giant
ice machine and the extra towels. Yeah.
And it's a fun show of SONA. You've seen
many of them. Yes. It's really fun show.
I'm at all the comics are amazing
actually. And how am I, you're good.
Oh Jesus. Anyway, it's been a blast.
It's a lot of fun.
And uh,
we are headed soon to Chicago,
Minneapolis and in Milwaukee.
So if you're in Chicago,
Minneapolis or Milwaukee and
you want to come see the show,
I guarantee you'll have a good time.
Grab tickets@teamcoco.com slash tour.
And so now I will get you a better room.
Do you have a window in your room? No,
I did ask them not to give you a window.
I don't think it's an actual room.
I sleep on the floor. Yeah,
that's a storage space.
Oh,
all right.
Well Conan's gone.
You said that you felt awkward
about being his friend.
It got a little contentious there. How
do you feel now after talking with him?
Will I feel so much better?
It's the longest conversation
we've ever had and I got, you know,
I've got to look into parts of his soul
that I wasn't able to look into before.
Yeah, I know. I don't. I definitely, how
do I say it? I don't feel as awkward.
Um, I know. Just feel slightly nervous.
Do you think it will happen? What?
Friendship. Oh mm.
That's a real long shot.
Look, I'm a pragmatist and uh, yeah.
If I had to put money on it. No,
thank you.
Yeah.
What is this now?
What are we doing?
We're going to listen to some
questions that fans have for you.
We're going to actually hear the fans.
Yes. You think they're going to be mean?
Yeah. Why? Cause when people don't
have to ask you something personally,
they can be mean about it.
But I think also people seem to like you.
It's just like being able to hear the
Internet. Yeah. Do you know what I mean?
These people have no fear of hurting
my feelings. This is just a scary,
yes, it's frightening. But go ahead.
Let's do it. I'm a great person. You are
Conan. How do you get your hair to
stand up like that? I just don't know.
Please tell me your secrets.
Um, that's a good question. And I did get
that question all the time. First of all,
it began naturally.
I just noticed
that my hair kind of sits up a
little bit and it has a spring to it.
And this is like when I was a teenager.
Okay.
I was a big fan of rockabilly
USIC and they will,
they comb their hair up and all that.
And so I,
I liked combing my hair up into a big
wave cause I realized I could do that.
And that, uh, it created kind of a look.
And then I was watching TV one day,
and this is a long time ago when it was
this actress named Victoria principle.
You remember her? You're making a confused
look. She was on the show Dallas. Oh,
okay. I'm really dating. I'm really
dating myself now. I thought you were.
Yeah.
So you saw the old I vain.
But there was this actress named Victoria
principal and she did a commercial and
she gave her hair tip, which she,
she dried her hair upside down men.
So I thought I'm going to try that.
So it was actually a teenage boy taking
advice from an actress who was speaking
to women and I realized I could make
my hair stand up even more to the point
where it got ridiculous.
And then it just became this weird habit
where I sometimes I would just try to
build it up into this big French
pastry that sat on top of my head.
And I was actually in Ireland once and
this guy was like standing by the side of
the road and I walked by and he went to,
good God, what do you feed that thing?
Wanting to my hair and now
I don't know how to stop.
Now I've become like big
bird or Mickey mouse.
I'm supposed to look a specific
way. I made myself a cartoon. Yeah.
Turned myself into an Emoji and
people want to see me be that.
And there were times when my hair
is flat and people are all upset,
like I'm a fraud. And I'm
like, okay, I'll go fix it.
And then I comb it back up again and
everyone's happy and I get a free latte.
Okay. All right. Moving on.
Hey Conan, which is your favorite
star wars movie of the prequels.
Thank you. This is Doneen from
Sacramento. Have a good day.
God,
the prequels or the ones that came,
there's the first couple that I
watched when I was young. Yes.
And then George Lucas
made a bunch later on.
It seemed to upset people. Right. There
was a jar jar. Oh, charge our banks.
Who's in it. Yeah, right.
There's a lot of those ones where they're
sitting around talking and it's very
bureaucratic and it's like Samuel
L. Jackson, is that right? Yeah.
Samuel Jackson,
isn't it?
Samuel Jackson's in it and in Yodas there
and a bunch of other leap blurps and
Glueck groups or they're just weird
aliens and they're saying if we're be
brought to a vote soon,
yes,
it will then go to the next
chamber of the House of the elders.
What do we do then? Hmm. Difficult. It is.
Maybe we can introduce bill as alternate
with rider on it and you're like,
why?
Why are we getting bogged down?
The whole thing is like a PTA meeting
and then they'll cut to a young Princess
Leia and she sulking and
then Ewan Mcgregor is around
doing something and then
back to the conference room
where they're like, oh,
didn't go well. Hmm.
This could take months.
Let's reintroduce pill.
Maybe we get ombudsman to support bill
and then using a legislative powers.
Hmm. Am I wrong about that? Yeah.
Well Princess Leia wasn't in them.
I'm so sorry. I just needed to make
sure you knew what. Oh wait, it's,
you're talking about, is it queen? I'm
a dollar or a princess on a dollar.
Can I just say,
can I just say thank you Matt?
Can I just say that I refer to all if
they're wearing a robe and you're the
object of someone's affections in a star
wars. I just called him Princess Leia.
That's the way I get through. Okay.
I'm sure star wars fans won't mind.
She's also a senator just
so we're covered. She's a
senator. Great. Yeah. Okay.
Well first of all, suddenly, oh look who
came to life over here with star wars. Oh,
call my name. Yeah. Am I not wrong, Matt?
That there's chunks of those movies
that are bogged down in the legislative
affairs of the rebel colony
or whatever they're called.
Literally the imperial Senate
and the Jedi Council Room,
which is just a round,
it's a round room and people were
bringing in papers and Yoda. I was like,
looks bad. It does. They use
the term trade disputes. Yeah.
There are trade disputes.
What a great idea.
That was the one thing that every kid
wants to see in their space epic is,
is a bunch of senators talking
about a tariff and a trade dispute.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah. It really is.
Like they were taking the minutes
of what happened was George Lucas,
he was probably in whatever
really nice enclave.
He lives in outside San Francisco.
Right.
And he had to go to the
DMV A and someone said, no,
you've got to get in that line
and then you have to mail it in.
And then he and Lucas was like,
yes, this is what star wars needs.
He was so pissed at the
Bush administration that
he named two of the alien
characters lot dot and newt gun right
after Newt Gingrich and Trent Lott. Well,
that's the stuff that age
is really well in films.
Can you see a 16 year old kid
chuckling at the Trent Lott joke?
What a mistake. Stay in
your lane, don't get it.
Don't get so enraged by the right that
you start warping your creative powers.
You know, it is. But anyway,
that's what I remember about that movie
is I watched 20 minutes of it and I
think they got a bill passed
and uh, and uh, it was, I was,
I was bummed out. Okay. Next question
is about a popular figure on your show.
So let's play it.
Tell me about Jordan, Jordan, your
favorite person and your staff.
That's unbelievable.
That guy has watched all
the Jordan remotes and his
assumption is that Jordan is
my favorite person.
Have you learned nothing?
Some of you are probably listening to
the podcast and have may not know what
we're talking about. Jordan Schlansky is
an associate producer on the show and I,
I started doing segments with him years
ago and people love it because he's got,
he's such a strange guy and uh,
he can be borderline rude to me.
Nobody knows what he does. And every time
I ask him, and this is not even a joke,
he says,
I have various duties and
responsibilities and I've asked Jeff Ross,
the executive producer and
Jeff's like those stuff. And
I'm like, what does he do?
He goes, stuff. So, I don't know. I
think Jordan has something on Jeff.
I think Jeff wants was in his Tesla and
backed up over an old lady and Jordan's
saw it and Jeff was like, just keep this
quiet and you don't have to do anything.
So yeah,
I know Jordan is not my favorite person.
I do think he's one of my favorite
comedy partners as a person.
No, he really can be very
irritating. Yeah. Yes.
Good wine recommendations and good
restaurant recommendation. Yeah.
But he'll talk about it for an hour
and 10 minutes. He has this manner.
You ask them about, well
what do you think? What kind
of wine should I get? Well,
traditionally the Malbeck
of course, uh, you know,
in this region because of
the earth and you watch,
and then he goes into
this stuff where he says,
you can actually feel the
sunlight in the olive oil.
When you taste this olive
oil, you actually tasting
the sunlight, the Tuscan sun,
and you're tasting the dreams and
disappointments. And you're like, no,
I mean I've,
a friend of mine asked him about an
Italian restaurant once and he goes, well,
you can go to this one which is at least
start on day or you can go to this one,
which is, but yeah, he's like,
it's your personal preference
and I didn't even know.
Those are two different things. I don't
think they are. Do they serve food?
Now he's out of his mind.
Conan O'brien
and Conan O'brien as himself,
produced by me, Matt Gorley,
executive produced by Adam Sachs and Jeff
Ross at Team Coco and Collin Anderson
and Chris Ben and at Earwolf special
thanks to Jack White and the white stripes
for the theme song,
incidental music by Jimmy Vivino.
You can rate and review this show on
apple podcasts and you might find your
review featured on a future episode.
Got a question for Conan,
call the team coco hotline
at (323) 451-2821 and leave
a message it to could be
featured on a future episode
and if you haven't already,
please subscribe to Conan O'brien. Needs
a friend on apple podcasts, stitcher,
or wherever fine podcasts are
now.
This has been 18 cocoa
production in association with
Godfrey's amazing colossal podcast.
Hi,
I'm Alan Alda and I'm a guest on Gilbert
Godfried. Amazing, colossal podcast.
You've got to listen to this. They
made me laugh. I left like this.
You were not prepared for what
a big star you would come after.
That was that great story about how
your face was more recognized to those
students than Lincoln's.
Isn't that weird? Bizarre.
And they tried it my
face and Lincoln's face,
and they showed it to schoolchildren at,
and during those years,
they recognized me more
easily than Lincoln.
And that's hard to believe
because he had his own penny.
Wow.
Join Gilbert, frank and their
guests. Allan, all that. This Monday,
wherever you listen to podcasts.